Tenemos el mismo rectángulo verde aquí arriba
y aquí abajo, y lo que quiero hacer es medir
su anchura, pero vamos a medirlo de dos formas
diferentes. La de este rectángulo de arriba la
vamos a medir en términos de cuántos clips de
ancho tiene, y la de esta de abajo la vamos a
medir en términos de cuántos centímetros de
ancho tiene. Así que comencemos aquí arriba.
Pausa el video. ¿Cuántos clips de ancho tiene
este rectángulo? Muy bien, ahora hagamos esto
juntos. Podemos ver que el rectángulo comienza
justo aquí y termina justo aquí, a la derecha,
si estamos pensando en su anchura, de modo que
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 clips:
podemos decir que este rectángulo mide 10 clips de
ancho. Ahora, para medirlo en centímetros, hacemos
lo mismo pero usaremos esta regla. Aquí tenemos
el borde izquierdo y el borde derecho está justo
aquí, y parece que este rectángulo mide 1, 2, 3,
4, 5 centímetros de ancho, 5 cm de ancho. Observa:
es el mismo rectángulo, tiene el mismo ancho, pero
tiene 10 clips de ancho y 5 centímetros de ancho,
de modo que tiene más clips que centímetros
de ancho. Es una forma de pensarlo. Ahora,
¿cuál de estas unidades de medida es más grande:
el clip de papel -al menos estos clips- o el
centímetro? Pausa el video para pensar en esto.
Bueno, lo podemos apreciar de forma natural:
si miramos un centímetro se ve más ancho que un
clip; pero también podría saberlo observando la
medición: utilizamos más clips que centímetros
para cubrir el ancho de este rectángulo, eso
significa que esta es una unidad de medida más
pequeña porque necesitamos más de ellos, entonces
esta es una unidad de medida más pequeña: el clip
es una unidad de medida más pequeña. Y luego el
centímetro es una unidad de medida más grande,
necesitamos menos centímetros que clips para medir
la anchura del rectángulo, así que el centímetro
es más grande, y podemos apreciarlo visualmente:
si comparamos esto con esto, está claro que
un centímetro es más ancho que este clip.